you're gonna miss the open it if you
guys keep whining about it let's go can
you tease about what you know about
season four cuz I know you know some
nuggets do I know I mean I know that
like I'm I mean I might have like a
separate storyline from everyone else so
we might be filming in like another
place but I don't really know I don't
know would you like to see from will in
season four I want to see you know
that's a good question I hope he's like
I hope he's happy but I really I love
when he's suffering cuz that's fun to
play three seasons of suffering I want
happy will does anyone has anyone ever
happy in the show
I hope so me do you think he'll find
happiness in this new town and now that
Elevens kind of like his sister
maybe maybe eleven I don't know I don't
know
I love doing comedy and I love putting
Mike and awkward awkward situations that
he would normally not be in because like
that's the most fun thing to play and I
think Mike when he's flustered is really
fun so I definitely want to do more
stuff with with that it would be cool to
see him have like some kind of job like
I want to say for so long I wanted to
see him work at the arcade at the Palace
arcade with Keith and have Keith fees
bought like you remember Keith from the
second season yeah I always wanted keys
to be his boss because they have that
rivalry and it's hilarious and I want to
work with Matt even more you sure about
that
sure about what and I want more singing
and I want more Suzy I think we all do I
think we all definitely do in season
four I don't know I mean I feel like
this season we got to see a lot of
different sides of her and I think where
we leave off in this season it's a very
you know interesting play so I'm excited
to see what the difference half-plant
they always surprise me just when they
think they're gonna run out of ideas
nope
they've always always got more in their
back pocket I really trust those
brothers to write something good you
know they come up with better things
than I could ever imagine I just you
know I hope she continues on this path
of believing in herself and you know I
love that this this investigative almost
Marie inspired journey of hers you know
I think it suits her and I think she's
really finding herself in it so I kind
of hope she keeps going in that
direction whatever you know it's like
where could they possibly go I have no
idea but they'll figure it out and I
hope that's where she's going
here comes in Oliver Twist routine I'd
like to kind of have more of a
relationship with Joyce this year
because I think the kind of relationship
between Joyce and Jonathan it has been
lost for a moment so it'd be great to do
a bit more with her I will see you
tonight yes would you personally like to
see for Joyce in sees it for oh gosh I
mean I feel for her and I want her to
find a sense of peace but also then
there's no show she's at peace you know
just more of her with the cast you know
I mean that's it's so
fun to work with everybody and it feels
so lucky what have they told you about
season 4 nothing
they really haven't theirs though like
actually this weekend I'm trying to sit
down with them to like talk about what's
going on because we didn't get a chance
we all ran off after the shooting and I
you know we haven't seen each other for
a long time and I was like guys let's
sit down and I actually was like before
this tonight let's sit down they were
like oh yeah man we can't we got a thing
we got a make up they've been like
dodging me they've been dodging me for
days so what I'm just supposed to let
them do whatever they want so I know
nothing I know as much as you I've seen
the final episode it's extraordinary
it's magnificent
what Hopper does and what happens to him
he acts like the person that he's meant
to be and then there is this mystery at
the end I don't really know what's gonna
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]